ありえない期待 願望からもう一つ経典を紹介します
真面目に
一回 ジャーティダンマーナン ビックウェーサッターナン エヴァン イッチャー ウッパジティ アホーワタマヤン ジャーテ
ィダンマ アッサ マナチャワタノー ジャーティ アガッチャヤーティ ナコーパネタン イッチャー イパッター バンビダン
ピャン ピッチャン ラビリ タンピ ドゥッカン
これは本当は暗記しておかなくちゃいけない文章なんですけど
ありえない期待 願望 第一
生まれる性質の生命にこのような期待が生じる
私は生まれる性質のものである
願わくは私には生生まれるということは起こらないことをと期待する
しかし これは期待で達成することはできません
これが期待は叶わないという苦です
で 生まれること ああ 私はなんで残酷な人間かと思う
残酷というか 惨めな人間か
生まれるんだ 死んでそれ生まれたくないんだと思っても
それは叶わないんだ 二度と生まれたくはない
生まれない 今生で終わりだと思っていても
それは違います で これは生まれることの人で
それから我々も生まれることっていうのは嫌なんですね
まあいろいろありますよ
例えば 家の誰かが病気になったりする
新しい状況生まれたんですよ
それが嫌と思っちゃうんです
だからいつでも生まれることもあります
自分が年を取るということも
新しい命が生まれることなんですよ
でも嫌なんです だから変化は嫌っていうのもそういうわけで
変化っていうのは新しくなるだけで
新しいものが生まれる
でも生まれることは苦しみになるんだから嫌になるんです
それから人生は嫌と思う人は
まあ生まれたくはないんだと勝手に思っても
そんな勝手に思ったっても生まれないわけじゃないんです
あるいは勝手に人生っていうのは一回で終わりますよ
生きていて死んだら終わりや
土に戻るんだとよく知ってることもいい加減な見解の天道なんです
ものを言うのは調べてデータを調べてからなんです
それもなく軽々 でもそれは起こりませんよと
あんた方勝手に思うことは
その期待は絶対叶わない
だから生命は絶対叶わない期待を持ってるんです
で 叶わない 2番目の願望
ジャラダンマーナン ビックウェーサッターナン エヴァン イッチャー ウッパジティ アホーワタマヤン ナジャラ
ダンマ アッサ ナチャワタノジャラ アガッチャヤーティ
ナコーパネタン イッチャー イパッター バンビダン ピャン ピッチャン ラビリ タンピ ドゥッカン
老いる性質の生命は 私は老いないようにと期待するが
期待は叶わないものです
これも期待は叶わないという苦です
だから誰でも老いるんですよ
老いるのは何歳からですか？年取るのは何歳からですかね
年ははっきりした方がいいんですよ
この何年何月何日から誕生日の老いることになるのかと
老いるということは お腹に命が現れた瞬間で起こるんです
その瞬間から老いていくんですよ
同じスピードで 我々天道だから
あ 成長していくんだ 成長するんだとかね
ああ 母ちゃん立ちましたとか
ああ 歩いたとかね 年取ったんですけど
だからどんな年から老いたと本人にも知らないんですね
同じスピードでずっと老いていて死んでしまいますよ
スピードには早くも遅くもないんです
老いるスピードは そこでまあ大体 30
40  50になってくると
年は取りたくないんだとかね
今更思っても いくらお願いしても
いくら神様に言っても
これこの期待は叶わないんだよと
お釈迦様が言うんです
叶わない期待を持つことがすごい苦しみだよ
年を取ること 老いることは苦しみじゃないんです
この期待  3番目 ビャーディダンマーナン ビックウェーサッターナン エヴァン イッチャー ウッパジティ アホーワタマヤン
ビャーディダンマ アッサ マナチャワタノビャーディ アガッチャヤーティ
ナコーパネタン イッチャー イパッター バンビダン ピャン ピッチャン ラビリ タンピ ドゥッカン
パーリ語ってすごく早く読めますよ
長く見えますけど 日本語の方が字がかかります
病気になる性質の生命は
私は病気にならないようにと期待するが
期待では叶わないものです
これも期待は叶わないという苦です
ほら 誰にも病気にはなりたくないでしょう
期待するでしょう 神社に行っていろいろやるでしょう
お札を持っていったりとかね
それは叶わないんです
神様にもどうすることもできない
それで
4番目 マラナダンマーナン ビッカレ サッターナン エワーミッチャー ウッパジタホワタ マヤンナ マラナ ダンマッサム
ナ チワタノ マラナン アガッチャイヤーティ ネコーパネタン イッチャー パッタ バンビ ダンビアン ピッチャン ラパニタン ピルカン
死の性質の生命は 私は私には死が訪れないようにと期待するが
期待では叶わないものです
これも期待は叶わないという苦です
で どんな人も死にたくはないんですね
だから仏教以外の宗教は
この不死になることを永遠の命
天国に行ったらもう死にませんよとか
あれこのように約束してくれたりして
これは叶わないんだよ
天国に行っても死にますよとブッダが言うんですよ
だから絶対あり得ない
叶わない 期待することというのはまた天道でしょ
またあべこべでしょ それで苦しみが生まれるわけです
それで生老病死で 4つですね
また入ります  5番目 ソーカ パリデワ ドゥッカ ドーマ スパーヤ サダンマ ハナン ビッカレ サッタ
ーナン エワーミッチャー ウッパジタホワタ マヤナ ソウカ パリデワ ドゥッカ ドーマノ スパーヤ サダンマ マーサ
マ ナチュワタノ ソウカ パリデワ ドゥッカ ドーマノ スパーヤ サダンマ マーアガッチャイヨンティ
ーナ コーパネタン イッチャーヤパッタッバン イダン ビアン ピッチャン ミラビリ タンピルカンということで
一単語はこれぐらい長いんだからね
一行になりますからね
でもそんなに難しくないんですよ
これパッと読みます そうか
パリでどこどまり スパーヤさんという単語なんですけど
で じゃあ意味 憂い 嘆き
悲しみ 悩みの性質の生命は
私には憂い 嘆き 悲しみ
悩みが訪れないようにと期待するが
期待では叶わないものです
これも期待は叶わないという苦です
誰にも嫌でしょ それが
憂いや悲しみやら悩み事やら悩みやら
私にはあって欲しくないと
じゃあお祈りしてみてくださいと
じゃあその願望をしてみてくださいと
ひどい目にあいますよ
それも期待は叶わないという
苦しみとか悲しみ  苦しみ
悲しみもあるはずなんですけど
書いてないね まあ皆様はよく読まれて知っているところですからね
意外に お教えの中にもありますからね
悲しみも入ってほしいんですけど
この 5つは期待で願望で祈りで叶えるものではありません
生命の本質なのです 魚は泳ぎたくない
泳ぎたくない 水は嫌いやと言ったとしても
もういい加減にしろ もういい加減でしょ
もう病気そのものでしょうに
天道そのものでしょうに
魚が水は嫌い 水は嫌いと
じゃあ行ってみればどうなるのか
水は嫌いだから水の中にいなくちゃあかんでしょ
だからものすごい大嫌いで
死ぬまでいなくちゃいけないんです
だから生きているものにとっては
生老病死 憂い 悲しみ 悩み
苦しみっていうのはまあセットで
それで生きているんです
生命の道なのです 生きるものたる故ですよ
生きるということはそういうことです
年取ることです 病気になることです
死ぬことです 死ぬことなかったら生きてもないんです
だから面白いことっていうのは
人間っていうのはそれが期待するんですよ
だから病気にならないように何か宗教でも作ったら
もう爆発的に売れるでしょう
まあ特別なお祈りやります
それだったら病気になりませんって宣伝がありますよ
赤穂城でも何か派手に火の祭りやりますからね
あれも一応自分も仏教の一部だと思ってるんですけどね
お釈迦様は断然的に禁止で言ったものばっかりやっていて
それであれ 病気になるんだから
50万人  500万人の人が集まるんだというふうに電車の宣伝にありました
それぐらい脳細胞を抜かれてる人々が日本にいるってことですからね
現実的な願望期待まで叶わないと言われていないんです
しかし お釈迦様が現実的な
具体的な 合理的な期待までも叶わない
そんなこと言ってないんです
あの 5つだけ放っておきなさいよ
あれは生命ということで言えば
魚であるならば水の中でのセットです
そこから上げることはできないんです
そこを理解して他の願望は叶えます
しかし 現実的であること
因縁を理解していること
その目的を目指して精進努力することが欠かせないんです
普通のその他の願望は叶いますよ
私はこの間も木曜日も言いましたからね
瞑想会 そんなの何のこともないんだけど
叶いますよと 人間の期待やら願望やら
でも人間期待するものはへんてこりんなこと
だから病気にならないように
年取らないようにとか
これはもう話にならない
これは苦という真理です
だから変わらないんです
真理ですから しかし 他のことは叶います
叶いますけど 条件があります
希望が現実的であること
因果法則がわかること
因果法則というのは この希望に達するために
何を何を何を何を揃えちゃえばいいのか
自分に何が何がないのかという因縁関係
それをわかってから目的を目指して努力すること
祈りでは叶わないんです
頭が良くなりますように
能力が向上するように
平和でありますようになどなど
それは叶いますよ もうちょっと仕事をうまくできるように
もうちょっと勉強ができますようにとか
もうちょっと点数が上がりますようにとか
今年の試験ではちょっとこんなもんだから
じゃあ次の試験ではこれぐらい上がりますようにとか
そういうのは具体的な願望だから
そんなのは叶います 平和でいられますようにと期待願望してもしたら
それはもう実現できます
保証は適用しないものはあります
また別な経典
チャトゥンナン ビッカレ ダンマナン ナッティ コーチ パティバホウ サマノワ ブラフ マノワ デーヴァ マロ
ーワ ブラフ マワ コーチワ ルーカス ミン カタメサン ジャトゥンナン
4つの事柄については
沙門バラモン 神も 沙門もバラモンも神も魔も悪魔も梵天も
その他誰にも保証はできないのです
この 4つとは何や いわゆる神であろうと悪魔であろうと
誰であろうとも保証できないものがあるんだと
いわゆるそちらの管轄以外
外です 偉大なる神様の管轄外のものは 4つあります
その 4つは何ですかね
ジャラダンマナンマジーラティーティナッティコーチパティバーゴサモノワーグラフノワーデーウォーマーローワーブラフマーワーコーチワーローカスミンカトメサ
ああ 降りた はい 老いる私は老いないようにと保証することは
シャモン バラモン 神も天も梵天も
その他誰でもできないんです
神様が来て 汝は老いないようにしてあげるし
保証しますとかあり得ないんだ
だから皆様方も神様を信仰している人々に言ってみてください
だってローマ法王もボロボロと人と死にますからね
あれ 神の代表者ですよ
人間と神の間なんです
そんな長生きしなくたって
例えば 150年ぐらい寿命を延ばしてもらっちゃえば
神に頼んで だってパイプパイプラインでしょ
神とに カトリック教の信者さんの間
そこで彼が言うのは 一人が死んじゃったら新しい法王を選ぶでしょ
その時選挙なんですけど
それでもそれは神が決めるんだ
だって一人一人が隠れた部屋にいるんですよ
隠れた部屋にいて 投票する紙に誰かのカーディナルの名前を書いて箱に入れるんです
お互い連絡は禁止なんです
一人選ぶまで外へ出さないんです
鍵かけてるんで 外から
偉いカーディナルたちなんですけども
普通 バチカンの仕事をする人々が鍵かけるんです
で ご飯とかは送りますけど
それは小さな部屋に隠れていて
そこで誰かの名前を書いて外に出す
出したら それをまとめて数えてみたら
もう誰も選べてない場合は煙でみんなに報告する
それで最初はみんな自分の名前を書くんだよ
さあ だから何回 何回 何百回も時々昔はね
1週間  2週間もいくんだよと
時間は それでカーディナルの中では 80歳とか
ボロボロ もう体が病気でクタクタ
今今死にそうっていうぐらいの人もいるんだけど
どうにもならん 閉じ込められたまんまでいなくちゃいけないんです
そこでごちそうは食わせてない
食わせないみたいです
みんなすっごいごちそうグルメですけどね
贅沢三昧でいるんで その時間は出してくれない
だからそこでどんどんみんなもう結果
一応教えてあげる でなきゃこれやりきれないんだからね
決まりを教えてはいけないんですけど
でも教えるみたいです
あの人は 10票  10票としたと
あの人は 9やと あの人は 7やと
あの人は 13だと あ そうか
では私には 3人しかないんだから
じゃあ俺の投票もあの人にそうということで
一人に投票が上がっていくんです
いわゆる 1票しかもらってない人は
2回目では自分の名前書きません
2票もらった人は 2回からは自分の名前書きません
それで大体 一人になるんだ
それが神が決めるんだ
それだったら 世間に神の威力を見せるために
ローマ法王は八十 百五十歳まで元気で健康でいて
パッと死んでもらえばすごいことですよ
どうったことない 我々とまるっきり同じで
パーキンソン病にかかるし
もう 鉄砲で撃たれたら怪我するし
厳しい警備がないとボディーガードないと命は危ないし
何のことはないんです
ということは 老いることは老いないようにと誰にも保証できませんよと
ビアーリダンマーナンテンテンマラナダンマーナン
同じ文章ですね 病になる私は無病であるようにと誰にも保証できません
死に至る私は不死であるようにと
いくらお願いしても いくら神様にも
いくら梵天であっても
悪魔であっても それはできませんよ
だから生老病死は神の管轄外なんです
で 最後だと思います
ヤーニコーパナターニパーパカーニカルマーニサンキリーシカーニポーノーバビカーニサガーニドゥッカイパーカーニアーイテンジャーティマラジャーティジャラマラ
ナマラニカーニテーサンヴィパッサナーニッパッティーティーというところで
汚れた転生を逃させる
今日なんでか読めないんですけど
になる まあこれは辞書を引いて入れたんです
あの富野ですかね いいの
えっ このいわゆる怖いっていうことです
あまり難しい漢字が読みたくない方々は怖い
でいいんです で 苦しみが報いになる
再び生老病死を気づく
犯した業に結果は現れないのにと保証することは
シャモンバラモン 神も悪魔も梵天も
その他の誰にでもできないんです
簡単な意味は 自分が罪を犯して結果だけをお願いしますから
出ないようにと これはダメですよ
だから人々は汚れた心でいろんな悪行為をする
その行為によって輪廻転生をする
どこに生まれても生老病死という絶対的な苦しみを味わらなくちゃいけない
だからそれはもう叶わない希望で悪いことに生まれたものは
それを期待するんです
年取らないこと 病気にならないこと
死なないこと で また悪い行為をする
また生まれでまた同じことになる
だから 自分が犯した罪に結果が出ないように何とかお願いしますと言っても
これは神様にも保証できませんよ
はい それで一旦休憩に入ります
今からあの 今日のテーマに入ります
あれもう今までずっと下げたのはもう最後のところ
ブッダの話  あれは